[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à manger c'est
beauté aujourd'hui en Normandie que les
plus connaisseurs auront reconnu
peut-être pas cette lumière changeante
entre les nuages mais en tout cas les
pommiers dans ce joli pré aujourd'hui
Agnès canaillé la sénatrice de
Seine-Maritime nous reçoit dans son beau
pays entre Seine et mer comme son nom
l'indique allez en route
[Musique]
ah j'étais sûr bonjour madame Chris
incroyable il a été mis en place pour
les 500 ans de la ville du Havre en 2017
et c'est vraiment symbolique de notre
belle ville portuaire est-ce que c'est
un endroit où se trouve les amoureux ici
oui c'est un endroit effectivement où on
flanne où on se promène on va faire les
amoureux mais de la Seine-Maritime
alors vous vous êtes natif du Havre ah
oui moi je suis une adresse pure souche
comme on dit chez nous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut essayer dans la dans la vie profane
et puis je collaborais aussi avec un
parlementaire Patrice là c'était élu
aussi du territoire à vrai alors
qu'est-ce qui vous a mené à la vie
politique parce que évidemment juriste
de formation passer sans doute par le
milieu associatif peut-être d'Antoine
ruffenac qui vous a un petit peu poussé
oui effectivement pas de l'époque le
maire de l'époque en fait c'est parti
moi j'étais j'y vais au Havre avec les
enfants impliqués dans ma vie
professionnelle et je rencontrais
souvent des gens qui me disaient tu
diras Antoine ruchnak tu diras
et donc moi j'ai dit bah écoutez
mesdames on va dire ensemble donc on
s'est réuni pendant trois ans on était
un groupe de femmes femmes actives
mobilisons-nous ensemble voilà c'était
notre allons-y et on a fait des
propositions Antoine Ruffenach de plein
de choses sur le périscolaire à l'école
le cul la culture au Havre etc et puis
en 2008 en temps de Reina qui a dit
c'est bien mesdames mais maintenant il
suffit pas de dire il faut faire donc
venez avec moi et donc dans l'équipe
embarqué voilà il nous a embarqué une
bonne partie du groupe dans son équipe
municipale en 2008 et entre les deux
vous avez pas eu envie de de la
députation qu'est-ce que vous a amené
vers le Sénat alors la députation j'ai
testé mais ils ont pas voulu de moi
élections
très compliqué oui bah c'est toujours se
confronter au suffrage universel sur son
propre nom c'est toujours voilà un
engagement
donc et ça tout ce que j'aime en
politique c'est le concret et c'est le
contact avec les gens et donc une
campagne électorale c'est au moment
d'aller rencontrer les gens de pouvoir
discuter avec eux et puis deux ans plus
tard effectivement après le
renouvellement de l'équipe municipale
c'est là où Édouard Philippe a demandé
de me faire élire au Sénat en me disant
je ne connais rien au Sénat
débrouille-toi pour te faire élire
la nationatrice puisqu'on est devant le
terminal des croisières d'ailleurs ça
rappelle que c'était le départ du France
vers New York alors c'est la base des
transatlantiques ici et aujourd'hui on
va faire une croisière en Seine-Maritime
et oui on va Fécamp je vous emmène vous
êtes à la barre c'est vous le capitaine
allez direction Fécamp
allez on quitte le port du Havre pour un
autre port historique la ville de Fécamp
à quelques kilomètres d'ici pour
rencontrer un pêcheur de coquilles
Saint-Jacques et puis nous irons
découvrir le Neuchâtel ce fromage en
forme de cœur cœur de la Haute-Normandie
ensuite déjeuner à l'EHPAD de Notre-Dame
de Gravenchon avec des personnes âgées
bien traitées au moment de passer à
table il sera temps ensuite de découvrir
les volailles fermières de anctiles père
et fils et ce ne sont pas des cyclistes
on terminera la journée à l'heure de
l'apéritif avec un bon verre de cidre à
piscicoville du cidre bio avant de
rejoindre le chef Gabin Bouguet devant
l'arche et l'Aiguille Creuse d'Étretat
pour une cuisine de Saint-Jacques allez
en route
[Musique]
à me laisser la triste ici on est à
Fécamp et on va voir Ludovic je crois
qui est patron de pêche voilà Ludovic
Yolan qui est patron de pêche ici qui
pêche la coquille Saint-Jacques en Baie
de Seine
bonjour Ludovic bonjour vous allez bien
voilà votre beau bateau le maximum alors
vous êtes armé pour la Saint-Jacques
c'est à dire c'est ce dispositif qu'on
voit là ouais c'est ça c'est les dragues
c'est les engins de pêche deux bâtons de
cette drague et on traîne de chaque côté
du bateau d'accord on gratte un peu le
fond avec des dents on appelle ça des
couteaux c'est des c'est des ce genre de
râteaux qui ratent un petit peu le fond
sur 10 cm à peu près on détruit pas le
fond marin on a vraiment léger quoi
c'est vraiment pour faire décoller la
coquille puis vu qu'on fait du Label
Rouge faut que la coquille soit vraiment
propre excusez-moi Ludovic j'ai un petit
doute là mais je vois que les caisses
sont vides là c'est le mauvais temps ah
oui vous êtes pas sortis
mais bon vous avez le droit de pêcher en
baie de scène oui j'ai droit j'ai le
droit de pêcher en médecine depuis que
j'ai coupé le nez du bateau coupé le nez
de 70 cm coupez le nez du bateau
pour avoir accès parce que je faisais
plus de 16 m et pour avoir accès au
gisement classé Benson il faut faire
moins de 16 mètres moi je veux voir ça
vous m'emmener en faisant oui allez-y je
vous accueille
[Musique]
voilà ah ouais ah oui carrément là
on dirait un canard dans une baignoire
qu'est-ce que c'est vos quotas Ludovic
j'ai droit 2000 kg par jour parce que
selon la taille des bâtons on a un quota
plus de 16 mètres c'est 2 tonnes 2 moi
je suis entre 15 et 16 mètres j'ai deux
tonnes 4 jours par semaine pourquoi 4
jours par semaine pour aussi préserver
la ressource pour préserver la ressource
on avoir quatre débarques par semaine
puis on est sur un marché vraiment frais
de la qualité de la qualité de la
coquille contrairement aux Anglais qui
font de la décortique eux ils font la
semaine à la mer
la semaine à la mer
et son 7 jours sur 7 à la mer donc ça
veut dire que pendant que vous vous êtes
retenu au port
vous voyez les Anglais pêchés
avant nous ou même l'été où on est
encore à terre pour le repos biologique
de cookie pour laisser se reproduire ils
sont à la mer et ils sont soumis à des
quotas néanmoins non aucun quota mais je
comprends pas est-ce que ça veut dire
que le gouvernement britannique se fout
de la ressource bah oui en gros c'est ça
c'est ça il y a aucune préservation de
leur source de leur côté
ce qu'on a mis du temps à préserver nous
viennent nous le payer à chaque fois et
on essaye de leur expliquer que même
pour eux en faisant des quotas ils
préserverait la ressource puis d'une
autre manière ils vont valoriser leurs
produits je suppose que le brexit a fait
du mal aux pêcher français ah oui oui
mais ça a été un gros sujet de né au
moment des négociations on a eu nombreux
échanges avec Michel Barnier à l'époque
était négociateur du brexit pour essayer
effectivement d'élargir les zones de
pêche et côte à pêche pour les pêcheurs
français notamment ceux du Range nord de
la Manche et plus particulièrement de la
baie de scène mais c'est des
négociations très compliquées et
aujourd'hui la France a réussi à élargir
un peu les quotas de pêche pour les
pêcheurs notamment de la Normandie et du
Nord mais ça reste pas égalité avec les
Anglais ce qui reste un vrai problème
heureusement qu'il a coquille
Saint-Jacques en Normandie parce que les
bateaux commencent à tous morts beaucoup
de bateaux de batailles on en serait
plus là on m'a diminué mes quotas et à
ça on voit la pêche industrielle qui
vient pêcher le long de nos côtes parce
que en fait vu que maintenant c'est
l'Europe qui gère ça l'Europe de de
mettre le pied dans
le pied dans le plat et nous défendre et
de dire stop stop à la pêche
industrielle de masse merci beaucoup
merci nous on va continuer notre périple
[Musique]
il était vraiment sympa de Saint-Jacques
on va où maintenant Agnès on va dans le
Pays de Bray voir Laurent et Mathias des
producteurs de Neufchâtel-en-Bray
Châtel le fromage de Seine-Maritime
celui du coeur
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs bonjour enchanté
bonjour Laurent même laisser
nutritionnellement on avait assez envie
de goûter le Neuchâtel mais on va
attendre d'abord de comprendre parce que
pour comprendre un fromage il faut voir
son terroir qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
pas de molle croûte fleurie
pas si molle que ça d'ailleurs
non quand le quand le fromage s'affine
il peut être assez ferme
et pourquoi vous avez choisi vous de
faire du bio
moi je me suis installé en
1996 après mon père et c'est une ferme
qui se transmette père en fils depuis 6
7 générations maintenant et à l'époque
j'arrivais avec des convictions
environnementales rendaient évident que
le les pratiques de l'agriculture dites
conventionnelle me paraissait moi à long
terme une impasse en terme d'atteinte à
la biodiversité
et puis de qualité des sols qualités de
l'eau vous êtes sur un territoire où
beaucoup de fermes ont mis la clé sous
la porte ici ou arrêter l'élevage
d'accord pour passer en polyculture ou
même en céréalier et vous avez
l'impression que c'est le bio qui vous
sauve
le bio et la transformation
des produits laitiers donc on va
chercher la valeur ajoutée du produit en
transformant le lait
c'est ça qui nous sauve et puis le du
coup c'est c'est nous qui décidons de
nos prix nos prix sont pas imposés par
le producteur de lait on leur achète le
lait à un prix qui n'ont pas décidé
qu'il aurait imposé
en tout cas moi j'ai eu le sentiment
vraiment d'être en phase avec les
attentes de la société et en phase avec
les enjeux environnementaux qui se
multiplient moi je pense vraiment que
l'agriculture biologique c'est une bonne
réponse à toutes ces problématiques donc
voilà alors qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire de plus Mathias maintenant que la
ferme est en bio comment est-ce que vous
allez faire un pas de plus vers cette
écologie qui est notre avenir à tous
j'ai lancé un petit atelier de volaille
de 250 l'objectif c'est la
diversification
l'objectif c'est la diversification
maraîcher à s'installer voilà diversifié
et c'est là on voit que c'est des vrais
entreprises ça demande une compétence
multiple et une addition de qualité
puisse applique la règle bien connue
chez nous de jamais tous les deux dans
le même panier donc je trouve ça
formidable cette diversification et et
voilà et de s'ouvrir à autre chose donc
si vous êtes d'accord Agnès il y a
beaucoup de discours de belles paroles
mais moi je juge quand couple le fromage
alors est-ce qu'on peut aller goûter
votre fromage on y va
[Musique]
alors je me demandais d'où ça vient
cette forme de cœur qui est quand même
particulière alors il y a une légende
qui dit que ça viendrait des femmes
normandes qui pendant la garde 100 ans
pour attendrir les soldats anglais alors
offrait des fromages en forme de cœur
oh c'était malin c'est romantique c'est
romantique et malin pour s'attirer les
bonnes grâces de l'ennemi les
stratégique on va goûter la stratégie
normande alors
[Musique]
et bien il est moins salé que ce que je
pensais prof de l'évolution
dans les techniques dans les techniques
fromagères et pas de cette présence
d'amertume c'est bon
formidable père
[Musique]
alors on a commencé par le plateau de
fromage maintenant on va aller déjeuner
en compagnie de nos anciens au bord de
la Seine alors là on est à Port Jérôme
sur scène anciennement Notre-Dame de
gravoux des torchères les raffineries
bien entendu et vous m'emmenez dans quel
genre d'établissement alors c'est un
EHPAD un EHPAD c'est un établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes et nous allons voir Claudine
et Alexandre qui sont des cuisiniers
dans cet état innovant local en circuit
court ils sont formidables
on arrive à l'heure des casseroles moi
ça me rassure qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de préparer chef nous avons une
sauce paprika qui accompagnera notre
cuisse de poulet ce midi
et avec une compotée de fenouil
excusez-moi même la directrice moi je
retire le masque je sens rien et dans
une cuisine
c'est mieux non on y sera ce potage on
l'agrémentant d'assaisonnement et puis
de crème parce que on est quand même en
Normandie
c'est bon reporte oui on a la chance
d'avoir donc du poulet et en plus pas
très loin donc notre producteur est tout
juste à côté
on pourra aller le visiter peut-être
alors
j'imagine
c'est un moment super important le
moment du repas pour eux ils attendent
ça je dirais avec impatience parce que
c'est ils attendent ça
depuis le matin enfin ils ont ils ont
pas beaucoup d'activités même la
directrice c'est important parce que le
moment du repas le plaisir du goût sont
des choses qui remontent très loin et
qui les rassurent quelque part donc
c'est un poste important dans le budget
dans une maison comme la bourse du
budget mais si vous me posez la question
de savoir à combien ça revient un repas
c'est le deuxième poste budgétaire de
l'établissement la restauration
Alexandre le à son budget moi j'ai le
mien on a le souhait des résidents voilà
c'est la gymnastique c'est rassurant de
voir qu'il y a une vraie cuisine parce
que on pensait pas des on se dit tout
arrive en barquette tout est réchauffé
sur place ça non ici cuisinier une
équipe de cuisine avec des casseroles
avec des vrais produits avec des
produits frais qui sont transformés bah
ça fait plaisir oui puis c'est vrai que
le fait maison quand même il y a rien de
tel et puis à porcherie dans un
établissement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes leur redonner ce petit goût
à la vie grâce aux aliments grâce à la
nourriture qui est quand même le cœur de
la vie et qui ponctuent leur vie
quotidienne c'est formidable donc c'est
extraordinaire ce qu'ils font ici
[Musique]
Claudine c'est du vin rouge
c'est autorisé parce qu'il y a pas trop
de mineurs ici
vous prenez pas de vin rouge mesdames
avec le fromage avec le fromage on a une
connaissance
tout pour le plaisir bon on attend le
fromage alors
non non
faut pas gaspiller la marchandise oh
c'est pas le genre de la maison
croyez-moi
[Musique]
alors nous sommes Vincent chez Laurent
et Arthur Antilles qui sont les
volailles du prieuré volaille du prieuré
je crois que c'est Laurent qui est là
effectivement bonjour bonjour Laurent
Vincent ferggio vous faites de la
volaille depuis longtemps oui depuis
1988 alors je suis un peu étonné parce
que je m'attendais peut-être pas aller
voir courir partout mais au moins qu'il
soit dans les prix ils sont où vos
poulets ils sont enfermés à l'intérieur
parce que on est en vigilant le
tripadviaire comme vous le savez
même ici en Normandie
il est très prudent de laisser les
poulets enfermer pour éviter justement
d'être de contaminer tous les lois en
fait
[Musique]
il fait chaud ici c'est chauffé ou quoi
non c'est pas chauffé c'est le poulet
qui chauffe
[Musique]
3300 poulets pour 400 mètres carrés ils
ont d'espace bah oui mais surtout
pourquoi 3300
[Musique]
pourri pour 400 mètres carrés pour qu'il
soit pour que le bien-être animal soit
bien respecté en fait heureux un poulet
heureux il pourrait en tenir plus
beaucoup plus oui dans des bâtiments
industriels par exemple ce serait dix
mille à peu près combien 10000 je pense
ouais Laurent si on se reportait 20 ans
en arrière on serait ici dans votre
exploitation mais vous faisiez du poulet
industriel c'était quoi la différence la
différence était déjà par la même souche
de poulet c'était du poulet blanc typé
pour être abattu à 42 jours 42 jours
c'est comme aujourd'hui aujourd'hui là
pour cela en fait voilà donc croissance
deux fois plus rapide trois fois plus
rapide
donc forcément avec un aliment plus
poussé avec
une densité au mètre carré beaucoup plus
importante donc forcément une litière
beaucoup plus souillée des émanations
d'ammoniaque beaucoup plus fortes pas
vraiment agréable à travailler non plus
dans cette configuration là et au
résultat un poulet qui est complètement
soufflé parce qu'on les voit ils ont pas
de forme de carcasse boule de chair sans
beaucoup d'eau la question qu'on nous
qu'on se pose en passant du modèle
industriel à un modèle beaucoup plus
vertueux fermier est-ce qu'on gagne
aussi bien sa vie est-ce qu'on la gagne
mieux
forcément qu'on la gagne beaucoup mieux
un gars il est dans plusieurs potes
économiquement on a déjà moralement
parce que tous les jours on est heureux
d'aller au travail déjà
et puis vendre en direct et ben on a
contact avec les clients tous les jours
et en plus vous vous avez l'abattoir sur
place tout à fait abattoir atelier de
découpe à 200 m d'ici donc ça un double
avantage évidemment on a pas nos propres
volailles et en plus il y a pas de
stress comme il y a 200 mètres d'ici
parce qu'on transporte nos bail on les
attrape la veille la nuit il lendemain
matin un bout de 200 m et ça arrive à
l'abattoir à 0 stress un policier des
posté est un poulet Christian poulet qui
a du goût
[Musique]
le poulain industriel il est pas fait à
la main comme ça j'imagine je pense que
c'est les gobelins
il va pas louper le meilleur morceau du
poulet ce qui s'appelle le sol illess
[Musique]
on doit rester vraiment indépendant mais
nous qui fixons le premier le client
s'il veut pas il veut pas terminé on y
va pas c'est notre prix c'est pas un
prix imposé d'accord et vous même
l'anciennettric c'est quoi votre morceau
préféré classiquement le blanc de poulet
ah ouais le filet le filet ça me donne
envie vous m'en mettrez deux poches s'il
vous plaît jeune homme merci beaucoup
Laurent à bientôt
ma nièce ça fait du bien ce petit rayon
de soleil après les gros nuages chez les
Antilles avec les volailles bon on a dit
qu'on allait boire un petit coup là oui
on va chez Pierre Lambart ou un mot du
Kenney à Pissy poville un producteur de
cidre bio formidable
[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour Vincent je suis en train de
regarder vos pommes dans le soleil c'est
magnifique exactement
on va dire vous serez Adam et Eve et moi
je fais le serpent d'accord
[Rires]
le choix du bio c'était purement
philosophique ou c'était la recherche
d'un nouveau marché de nouvelle
clientèle très honnêtement les deux à
l'intention jusque je me rendais compte
que on va un peu dans le mur les phytos
les phytos en plus il y a de plus en
plus de restrictions de moins en moins
d'efficacité une demande sociétale qui
est là et puis bon il y a un aspect
marketing clair que je voulais que je
voulais mettre en avant différencier par
rapport aux autres
clairement ça va pas apporter grand
chose en termes de business si on peut
dire le revenu non ça a pas grand chose
clairement je me pose la question
d'arrêter de bio parce que ça devient
j'ai commencé à convertir en bio en 2016
donc on devait faire des légumes de
plein champ bio ok les gars allez-y
allez-y faites du légume fait du légume
fait du légumes du plein champ
un débrouillez-vous si vous pouvez faire
un million d'euros d'investissement par
culture il y a plus de marché il y a
plus rien alors sauf cette année c'est
une sécheresse mais alors qu'est-ce qui
vous pousse aujourd'hui à continuer le
bio vous êtes engagé dans une voie et
vous pouvez pas faire marche arrière
c'est ça
ben oui je suis engagé parce que je suis
engagé pour 5 ans à le faire
effectivement donc si j'arrête avant je
devrais rembourser les équipements les
aides que j'ai perçu de lieu et
européenne
[Musique]
je vous fais goûter du cidre
ensuite ça fait de la cuve et Gustave
qu'on a fait vieillir 6 mois en fût
d'eau de vie donc tous les tanins du de
l'eau de vie se sont transférés aussi et
ça donne un site avec une complexité
aromatique très intéressante
[Musique]
oh là là
ça monte au nez c'est extraordinaire
effectivement un deuxième goût un goût
du cidre derrière ça le goûte notre vie
tout à fait et pas seulement j'irai même
que ça le goût du chêne aussi on sent un
goût boisé on le sent un peu sur la
langue effectivement le tanin le tanin
on va prendre la route alors on va
peut-être pas finir nos verres
responsable merci beaucoup pierre je
vous en prie merci de nous avoir reçu
cette délicieux
[Musique]
alors je vous emmène voir
Gabin Bouguet le chef du donjon ici à
Étretat qui est étoilé au Guide Rouge et
qui vient d'être identifié comme grand
de demain par le guide goyio autrement
dit un grand chef
bonjour Chef bonjour ça va Gabin
bienvenue bonjour
de mettre le tablier de cuisine parfait
l'Espagne
[Musique]
avec un taboulé de butternut très léger
donc on le passe le long de la coquille
du haut pour couper le muscle c'est ça
faites attention à vous moi ça m'ennuie
avec quand même comment vous allez
signer les lois après
heureusement et en fait électronique
[Musique]
chef la partie un peu plus compliquée
c'est sortir en laissant les bars
et vu comme ça
super
je vous laisse avancer un petit peu
parce que je vois que il y en a de la
Saint-Jacques quand même pendant ça j'ai
quelques questions à vous poser Agnès il
y a eu un passé agricole glorieux et
riche on est obligé de penser à cette
Normandie de Flaubert et de ce qu'il
dépeignait au 19e siècle et puis au 20e
siècle ça a perduré et puis évidemment
Chris successives difficultés de vivre
les agriculteurs c'est plus les riches
agriculteurs normandes telles qu'on les
imaginait jadis non c'est vrai mais
l'agriculture de Normandie a quand même
su au moins ici en Seine-Maritime garder
à son équilibre économique en faisant de
la polyculturellevage c'est à dire que
chez nous on met jamais tous les œufs
dans le même panier parce que la terre
est riche la terre est riche la terre
produit alors et le climat est plutôt
bénéfique pour les cultures pour
certains types de culture
vous m'avez parlé des atouts maintenant
c'est quoi les défauts de la
Seine-Maritime on a un handicap c'est la
liaison ferroviaire le jour on nous
rétablira un train qui reliera le Havre
à Paris dans des les raisonnables avec
des fréquences raisonnables on a encore
plus d'attractivité de notre territoire
et je pense que aujourd'hui et c'est ce
qu'on défend beaucoup au Sénat c'est la
proximité je crois qu'on a besoin dans
cette mondialisation d'avoir aussi
localement un ancrage et la commune le
territoire c'est aussi des repères qui
sont importants
[Musique]
et qu'on les fait venir chez nous bien
et nous aussi on va vous attraper et
vous faire venir chez nous sur Public
Sénat pour manger ses beautés à bientôt
ils sont là regardez
[Musique]